My way, I
've had
this strange variant many times where I
always stand strangely with black and don't get anything right with white.
It actually looks like a good
Benoni Volga, somehow swapped around
because it somehow looks quick with white
Tempos somehow and bishops on
G7 and E7, the two parts are not
exactly ideal,
but above all I wanted to
accelerate a bit here,
so open up the diagonal and
plan
to get to B4 with the knight later,
yes it is fulfilled  of course as usual
ambitious
yes the point is just what about E4 yes
I'm standing on it three more times
and I don't know but really but
really get it done
take the three jumps the four then
such an action can maybe work
yes I would like to then B1  and then
play knight B4
with a company then it can only
be right for me
or he lets me of course five well
four is now the big question
if I take then takes the three
but
so yes now knight B4 no yes
yes actually looks good for
white  I would think that I'm very quickly
in the gutter wing and now I'm in danger of
taking it quite stupidly,
sometimes apart from the
knight D5 and if he takes the knight
then the question is, I think I
would take with the queen and then
maybe even swap the queen
then in the end
there is actually only pressure left on the b-line
and he still has a strange,
strange bishop so, well, he's making a
wave right here now,
okay, but that falls, that's what I'll take for
now,
so the next move is the 4th
I can't believe the security for Black with all the active pieces,
but it's still somehow complicated
so
you want to hit
on F5.
C5 is also considered, yes, a whole
lot comes here with costume
do like seven, yes we can make all
possible moves maybe good, go
ahead  I want to see where he
goes with the queen,
of course he takes a
protecting pawn from the knight but
I don't really know where he wants to go,
knight queen E5 but let's say
C4 there we have G6 also looks stupid
somehow because he is  then put it in this
fork
that doesn't threaten to get dirty yet but
since we have E6 Springer C7
yes so
yes that was my idea was now here then
to beat
the one for the idea now if he just like that
now calmly so that C6 once directly no
because of that  because of this position here with
the knight 7 and the second idea is
to simply take here now and
then bishop E4 so that you can
play properly on the white squares here
with the queen taking
C6 again, so the rook takes bishop  E4 So
now all the parts here should actually start
rolling
I'm stupid Thomas
A8 then I don't know because he
wants to play now yes that or done
but now I can take C6
so well
a knight should move I
actually don't want to  Give up E2 but
at the moment I don't see how
I can avoid that
a moment, a moment, a moment, a moment,
bishop E4 so that the two queens G6
yes, that looks good or bishop E4
so that the two queens G6
yes
over, that's it
king  G8 is coming Springer i7 yes and back then
he couldn't cover
yes I liked it, it looked
pretty good I think
yes let's try it I think he
really lost a lot of time here no
and this F5
expansion here also has major
weaknesses no I think  somehow here
with so that knight B4 here would have to be
at h66 no, whether black
can maybe do something different here but I do
n't like it, I just know
very quickly yes on the b-line on the
dam wing